[Music]
amy is left-handed so this is either a
sin for amy's severe organizational mind
not using the mouse on her natural side
or for the pressure left-handers field
to adapt to a right-hander's world
you pick i'm about to give captain holt
his gift oh
did he lift his no gift policy no then
why did you get him a gift amy if
someone has a no gift policy it is for a
reason that falls under the filing of
none of your [ __ ] business
so instead of forcing your goodwill on
them how about you just let them be
you think you're being nice but you're
actually just being terrible
so just to recap you left an unmarked
package on a police captain's desk on a
random monday with a suspicious message
written on it looked like it was
scrawled by a crazy person
bomb there's a bomb in 60 seconds this
show sets up a perfectly constructed
joke and payoff based on authentic
character traits and actions and retains
its crown as the king of the cold opens
great gift babe dating co-workers is
rarely a good idea but calling your
girlfriend babe while in the workplace
environment
doubles the sinful pleasure you got that
handsome i proclaim that this slo-mo
power walk should have hitchcock and
scully laboring behind to keep up
and i will not be convinced otherwise
heart attack soda i thought they banned
it
not in syria they used it to induce
labor and goats smugglers
also somewhere there's a syrian goat
struggling to start the delivery process
that is paying the consequences of your
callous actions boyle
for susan the goat it's as cold as the
waters of cochitis
the frozen lake of hell technically
kokitis is a river in most greek
mythology it's only dante that makes it
a frozen lake and nowhere is a specific
temperature mentioned so this feels like
complete conjecture on holt's part
i'll see you there i can't wait to dunk
my junk
genital shaming gina it's our first
annual boiling eddy christmas
does anyone enjoy the forced coupling of
these two and even if you do did it
actually make sense that they would be
together in any way shape or form
it's real life die hard show insinuates
that die hard isn't a true story
we get some hairspray make some flame
throwers let's fry these [ __ ]
no one is frying any [ __ ] based on
how that word is being thrown around
this feels more like a real life live
free or die hard charles did you call
this in a dispatch
yes but i can't get in touch with anyone
from the nine-nine right because the
only police that could assist you are
your direct friends
oh well on with the die-hard shenanigans
dinana hearts
i'm in my family which is my number one
priority
it has a do not disturb setting terry
there are multiple gunmen they've
blocked all the exits they've taken the
security guards hostage and they clearly
have really bad hearing because you
might not think you're making a lot of
noise peralta but you are
i am not enjoying this no matter how
much it is 100 my favorite movie come to
life
100 i mean i could basically spend the
next five hours listing the various ways
this
isn't die hard come to life so i will
it's not in a tower
you aren't visiting your estranged wife
you don't have two kids
it's not in a tower amy doesn't work for
a japanese business
christmas in hollis is never played it's
not in a tower i'm sick of
hearing you got things brewing i'd just
like to point out that terry takes the
time to settle a family score directly
after finding out that his friends are
in a dangerous hostage situation i mean
putting your family in their place is
important but terry has time for this
kids i love you sharon you are perfect z
get a job
taking away what i just sinned i don't
know if i've given a sin off for terry
crews yet so i'm making sure we do here
because he's the silent weapon in the
nine nine
okay we should be safe in here this
place looks good what is jake basing
this on they're still in an open area in
the store and furthermore this place is
lit up
literally like christmas should they
find a darker corner somewhere with
something to hide behind or even under
here's the situation 12 terrorists one
cop just the way he likes it because
that's the tagline from the die hard
poster
i mean technically it's 12 terrorists
one cop the odds are against
john mcclane just the way he likes it
which makes sense because it's
insinuating that mclean performs well
when he's up against long odds
your way just sounds like he's into some
sort of terrorist orgy fetish
where's gina i don't care how deep you
are into this hilarious die-hard
deconstruction there is no way you don't
see gina leave your immediate area when
she was right next to boyle
jake they're taking gina i know we're
looking at the same thing
jake would be a 1010 at tv since i
thought he was on his massage tour of
southeast asia
is it possible some things are even too
gross to put on your grossest characters
i know what's going on here jake wants
to go solo and he's trying to steal my
thunder
is there really any thunder to steal
here i know it's a hostage situation but
it's a few robbers ripping off a
department store in new york on
christmas eve if the vulture is lucky
this would make page 33 in the times and
it probably wouldn't even include a
picture
tell him that i'm liam neeson and he's
my hot dumb daughter
taking the liam's name in vain taking
the liam's name in vain
taking the lord's nissan in vain taking
the takens nissan and liam
ah you write this one
[Music]
good thing they suited up so quietly i
would hate for the bad guys to have been
tipped off by
loud noises like breaking bulbs or
cracking skulls or grunting robbers
also gunter's reaction is so delayed to
that hit across the face that i swear he
was counting mississippis
uh yeah i was ooh but now i'm back eh
making fun of canadians actually that is
kind of enjoyable but
still probably a senior hoser i can't do
it i'm a wimp just like you said
whoa in the time between we last checked
in on this important and oh so hilarious
amy doesn't like goldwater b-plot
i had forgotten it even existed it
seriously took my brain about five
seconds to figure out why rosa and amy
were at the beach in the dark
be honest you're judging me i'm really
not i am
a bit no lies on christmas and why is it
okay to lie on the other 364 days i mean
seriously i'm not judging i want to know
the answer to that because clearly i
haven't been dishonesting right did
anyone at this annual cold swim actually
go under the water
it's a polar plunge not a polar
thigh-high weight in you wimps we have
to tell terry they're escaping through
the sewers they're pulling a shawshank
and a die hard on the same night now
you're just over referencing
i think people who believe he threw
himself in the garbage just tell him you
were chasing him while riding a luck
dragon
the falcore defense is now common law
precedent so you should be in the clear
i'm not sure which is more ridiculous
the peralta just happens to have
hairspray right in hand to toss to gina
that he would toss it to her knowing she
wanted to create a homemade flamethrower
or that
um this works
i don't want a nice hotel no touristy
place
something really indicative of the
people in their culture despite popular
belief we love movies and we love
talking about them check out the
scenecast podcast where i'm joined by my
fellow cinemasins creators to talk about
movies rankings rants and more available
here on youtube
or search for scenecast wherever you
stream podcast thank you for this
amazing year
thank you for the food in front of us
i'm in my family
my two beautiful beautiful handsome
striking sons
walker and texas ranger oh man that's
cold it's freezing
my balls just turned into prunes my
balls have turned into raisins
hey matt are you in position your name
is matt chat
oh great the bad guy's name is matt hi
i'm matt i'm a radar technician
look around you i control all of this
i'm the world's greatest douglas fir
i'm the perfect shape i'm the perfect
color
my scent like making love to a
lumberjack
now let's go out there and gear our
asses up quietly
i will end your career i will thank you
got the chief not only that you
sacrificed your john mcclane moment
well i should probably go pick up my dog